[Music]
welcome to the reason Roundtable your
weekly podcast from the magazine of free
minds and free markets even during
difficult moments I am Matt Welch joined
by Nick Gillespie Peter suterman and
Catherine mangyu Ward happy Bank Run
everyone
hey Matt
howdy happy Monday this is the most
unhappy by the way the Monday after
daylight savings oh it's grumpy Monday
there's a lot of grumpy Mondays in my
world Catherine so it's kind of you get
in line
uh we are that's a preview of things to
come by the way uh we're taking this
upset about Matt I'm not here I'm not
doing would win the Oscar or something
I'm not doing Gestalt therapy with you
uh yet Nick
that's our next uh iteration we are as I
am looking at the clock here taping this
at 1103 a.m on a Monday morning let's
check with our Dow Jones Industrial
Average desk and see where where we're
at right now it is we're up 263.57
points nicolesby that's uh
0.83 uh all of which will be absolutely
meaningless by the time anyone hears
this but it's important to be panicked
or perhaps outraged or just snickering
in the general direction of obnoxious
Tech Bros uh in the wake of two bank
failures first on Friday the Silicon
Valley Bank
the nation's 16th largest was taken over
by California Regulators After
experiencing a withdrawal run by panicky
depositors including a lot of technology
related companies who were all rightly
worried that the bank's over exposure to
U.S treasuries of all things after the
past months of rising interest rates
left it unable to cover its bets
normally the Federal Deposit Insurance
Corporation or FDIC will cover just the
first two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars of any single depositor after
that you're on your own Sucka but over
the weekend the FDIC and Federal Reserve
announced that all depositors would be
able to get all of their money due to a
systemic risk exception great punk band
name as if to prove the
systemicness systemicity Catherine yeah
the announcement uh covered the deposits
of a second financial institution the
Signature Bank of New York which was
closed Sunday by state Regulators the
feds claimed that quote no losses
associated with the resolution of
Silicon Valley Bank will be borne by the
taxpayer
and quote President Joseph Robinette
Biden II added the solution also ensures
that taxpayer dollars are not put at
risk countered Elizabeth Nolan Brown in
today's reason Roundup yes it's a
bailout and yes it's unwise damn ENB
Catherine I read in the financial time
so it must be true because of the pink
paper uh that uh quote svb
shows that there are few Libertarians in
a financial Foxhole is uh the Ft right
and or does reasons uh seemingly uh
hostility that's language
um just show that we're not uh clients
of svb and the Signature Bank
you like the pink paper
they are otherwise Miss ided here um of
course there of course there is such a
thing as a principled Libertarian and
this is just like absolutely absurd to
suggest otherwise
it is true however that many people do
abandon their principles when their
bottom line is at stake there is nothing
special about Libertarians in this
regard people are wishy-washy jerks all
over the political spectrum and some
people who had previously said things
about how markets should be left to
function on their own are probably now
saying please bail us out but uh there
are just as there are in fact many many
many atheists in foxholes there are also
Libertarians in Bank runs and it's
utterly infuriating to imply otherwise
including for instance reasons own
journalists on this subject uh in pieces
that have been published
in the hours leading up to this podcast
Peter um Catherine's Harvard uh
boyfriend Larry Summers tweeted over the
weekend that I thought you were talking
about my literal husband who oh to go to
Harvard did he wait you are better than
Hilary Summers I thought you were
married to Dan I am married to Larry I
said boyfriend okay come on
too Matt I love him your husband was so
good in The Social Network
Solari Summers uh said over the weekend
that quote this is not the time for
moral hazard lectures or for lesson
administering
dude rights like I do uh or for alarm
perfect time about the political
consequences of bailouts did you hear my
scare quote there but uh now I'm talking
now not Larry Summers for once uh but uh
Peter isn't it though uh shouldn't uh
companies be cognizant of their of the
250 000 limit and like when uh times of
Woe are happening like say suddenly
after a lot of years of zero interest
rates were hiking up really fast that's
a time for those over 250 000 uh people
to maybe like check to see if their Bank
isn't being totally ridiculous yes
that's correct and look Justin Amash uh
not surprisingly is correct here a
bailout creates a moral hazard he
tweeted even if it's just a bailout of
depositors at a bank it doesn't fix but
instead exacerbates the systemic problem
and the Public's always on the hook for
the cost of any fed program no matter
how much government insists uh costs
won't be paid by taxpayers right so
first of all Bank taxpayers and they are
paying they will end up paying into the
fund that is covering these losses
second of all banks are going to end up
more regulated because of this and that
is going to raise costs for banking for
normal people but the the whole point of
that 250 000 limit is that there is
supposed to be effectively a kind of a a
market a crowd-sourced risk
um risk measurement that is going on at
all times right so people are supposed
to say hey you know what uh I'm
protected up to a certain point however
I'm not going to stick all of my money
into a bank that might have a lot of
risks because I know that then those
risks are also mine and what the FED is
basically saying here what the FDIC is
basically saying here is actually those
risks aren't yours and there is never
any reason for someone who is a
depositor to worry uh to think about to
to concern themselves with the possible
risks of the institution that they are
banking with
what is that going to do that is going
to incentivize people to bank with banks
that are doing risky stuff and that are
making bad decisions because what when
because when you say that you're going
to bail them out no matter what what
you're saying is your mistakes your bad
decisions uh your risk taking is not
going to cost you and it's not gonna
cost anyone else either and so what
they've done here is they've basically
said look Banks you can make the exact
same mistakes that Silicon Valley Bank
has made over the past couple of years
and you can keep making them and because
we think you are systemically important
and we're going to use the word systemic
which has like a totemic power now in
cultural and political debates right
just all across the the Spectrum here
whether it's systemic racism or you know
systemically important Banks right
because it's systemic that means that we
can step in and the thing is that that
what they've done is they have made the
bank banking system at minimum more
prone to Future bailouts and likely more
prone to risky behavior in the future
that is going to keep causing these
people uh you're almost as old as Hugh
Grant
um although with a much better skincare
routine yeah I was going to say a lot
less crinkly uh I loved uh seeing him uh
you know just kind of cellophane out on
the red carpet and also seemed to have I
think his cheekiness was masking
cognitive decline
oh
I think we can talk about that later
maybe I want to talk about that now but
I will be he is a better actor than he
has ever been but I don't think he's all
there anymore uh it's you know
Paddington too what does that say about
the about acting right you know ask
Ronald Reagan he had the role of a
lifetime when he barely knew how to put
his shoes on
uh so we've been doing this and by this
I don't mean uh witty banter about Hugh
Grant uh I mean uh bank bailouts for
about four decades now uh SNL crisis in
the early 80s we had the Mexican peso
bailout
that was their Savings and Loan not
Saturday night thank you um which by the
way needs to also die I think it's been
bailed out enough but it and SNL did
have a crisis in the early 80s that was
some rough okay so tell Eddie Murphy
Charles rocket right uh there is
long-term Capital Management let's not
forget that poor 40 out yeah yeah uh
yeah the bank bailouts of 2008-2009 uh
those paid everything back that's why
everything is so good now Matt that's
right uh kovid obviously the trillion
dollar fire hoses uh how do you Nick
Gillespie uh Hugh Grant uh of of of New
York City how do you think over time
this has affected
kind of the basic social contract of
banking
oh God I don't know about that but
there's absolutely no question like we
fixed this didn't we with Dodd-Frank
uh and with a million other
interventions so this could never happen
again because nothing would ever be too
big to fail or whatever and we're
talking about a bank that was like the
20th biggest bank in America the fact
that it's situated in Silicon Valley
obviously plays a role in this I do want
to point out that the other bank that
failed signature has a uh Mr Bernie
Sanders on its Board of advisors which
is yeah I don't know that's a little bit
creepy but I was reading uh the most
interesting thing I read about this was
actually written in
2019 by Sheila bear the former chair of
the FDIC who when Hank Paulson and uh
and Timothy Geithner to and Ben Bernanke
talked about a they'd come they came up
with a plan for how to really bail
things out if in case you know it
happened in 2019 because they had
published a book or whatever and she was
like you know what you can can't keep
doing this like that's a really bad idea
there are FDIC limits in that uh the
purists Among Us can take real you know
bitter umbrage at all of that that
should you know Banks shouldn't be
guaranteed bank deposit shouldn't be
guaranteed at all but this is an
absolutely outrageous Flex by the
government you know coming you know
where in recent memory we did this for
the last time for the one and only time
this is just it is it's horrible and
it's a reminder just as we've already
forgotten many of the mistakes and
lessons learned from covid lockdowns and
how foolish they were and how dumb
policy was we learned all these lessons
you know a dozen years ago and here we
are now just doing the same thing over
and over again in order to stabilize the
economy blah blah blah as I think Peter
said you know there's going to be a
bunch of new bank regulations that come
out of this that will make sure that
this doesn't have happen again for you
know five or ten years but it should be
it should be extremely outrage outraging
to everybody so can I actually just say
something here since Nick brought up
covid because I think that uh that
people are underrating the role that
covid policy played in played in the the
bank meltdown here right this is this is
the compound effect of years of terrible
policy and not just previous bank
bailouts because in some ways what
happened here was that during covid tech
stocks and tech companies and startups
just got absolutely flooded with cash in
part because people were staying home
using technology right and so that's
where they were that's where people who
had money to spend were spending their
money on on digital virtual stuff that
they could access online which meant
that the tech startup world was just
absolutely booming because the tech
startup world was absolutely booming
they had a bunch of extra money and they
needed to bank that money somewhere so
they put that money in Silicon Valley
Bank well now Silicon Valley Bank had a
bunch of extra money and what they did
with that money was they invested it
basically in in government bonds that at
the time were really quite low interest
and then what happened of course over
the past year is that interest rates
have started going up uh in part because
the FED is trying to to Tamp down on on
the inflation that it was at least
partially and arguably substantially
caused by all of the money that the
federal government spent during covid to
give everybody a lot of money so they
would be able to buy a lot of stuff
online and right and so if you if you
sort of rewind the clock several years
and we hadn't done a year of people call
them lockdowns let's just say business
closures and like a very very strong
cultural expectation that everybody stay
the [__] home and not go anywhere and
just like binge Netflix for a year we
hadn't done that
then this probably wouldn't be happening
we would probably not be in this
situation if we hadn't wildly
overreacted first to covet in terms of
social expectations about what people
are going to be allowed to do and second
in terms of fiscal of the fiscal
response of spending uh about six
trillion dollars depending on how you
count it over the course of about a year
to to give money to to people directly
to give money to companies right to just
inject a huge amount of money into the
economy and all of this is a is a
compound result
of years at this point of really really
terrible response
also just to build on that real quickly
the you know it's also if you wind it
back to 2008 uh in the beginning of 2008
George Bush did a stimulative uh tax cut
to families with kids Obama pushed that
into new territory there was also the
tarp stuff like we have been a bailout
Nation for a long time now and I I agree
completely with what Peter was saying
and it also it kicked you know it kicked
the it broke the glass ceiling on the
federal budget to a point we're going to
be talking about uh Biden's budget I
know in a bit but it's like it's we are
spending Unthinkable amounts of money
and it just keeps going up and up and up
and so these are all things like this it
really I think it comes back to the you
know the end of fiscal responsibility
that really started with joy George W
bush and his first couple of budgets I
mean we need to remember that he
basically increased federal spending by
50 percent in eight years in real terms
and that of course goes beyond just War
spending which uh Nick yeah absolutely
increased domestic spending uh you know
by that much Catherine we've already
referenced Dodd-Frank a couple of times
here uh and as Nick was was talking
about how Dodd-Frank was the it was
going to prevent this from ever
happening again let's not forget that
sarbanes-oxley was going to prevent this
from never happening again which was
passed in the wake of Enron both were
described in almost identical Language
by the presidents signing them under law
as like containing this once and for all
uh Joe Biden Catherine not your
boyfriend uh this morning
um said as part of his uh reassuring
remarks to the nation
that uh some of the blame for what
happened perhaps uh can fall on the
shoulders of Donald Trump because he uh
rolled back some of those Dodd-Frank
regulations that were going to make sure
that this never happened again uh I uh
remember kind of through the long
coveted Haze that at the right is the
great financial crisis happened in
September of 2008.
um I think I assigned you to like take a
searing uh moral inventory of uh whether
deregulation as everyone was saying I
mean everyone was saying except
Matt Kibby was the only one not saying
this at the Time Michael Flynn God Rest
his soul
um uh but uh to take a look like hey
look did did we get there because of
deregulation remind us of what you found
in those pokings and uh what that might
tell us uh or just like kind of frame us
as we process similar claims this time
around
yeah I mean it's they were exactly they
followed exactly the same template of uh
of blaming the most recent minor
rollback of a regulation in the banking
sector which remains one of the most
regulated sectors in our economy like
the idea that as and of course Nick said
in his nice old man voice glass-steagall
which was at the time the thing that
people talked a lot about the partial
repeal of the glass-steagall act in 1999
was somehow to blame for
um
for the crisis in 08 this is not the
case this is simply wrong the the the
political incentives are to look at the
latest deregulation if you like
regulation is to look at the latest
little deregulation and say it's
probably that
um the reason that I thought you were
going to talk about my actual Harvard
boyfriend husband uh when you were
talking about Larry Summers is that
um I had a convenient in-house expert on
Venture Capital since that is the
industry in which my husband now works
uh this weekend who was
um
sort of uh he was like a snowball of
anger as the as the week I went on
because if you're a Libertarian in BC
right now you're not a happy person and
uh you should know about him that he is
generally uh less inclined I would say
to profanity than I am and so it's
meaningful when he says parents cover
your children's ears we keep [__]
bailing these [__] [__] out that's
what he said I could quote him on um he
was very upset about it as uh texts
rolled in last night saying thank
goodness woo everybody's safe
um wrong lesson learned right
um so his account of this uh is actually
one
in which you can at least tell a
plausible story that it was regulations
that contributed to this Bank Run
specifically
um and he pointed to a couple things
that I just wanted to raise one is
um
you know as as Peter described you know
we had this situation where obviously
this is all in response to the raising
of interest rates like that's where the
kind of initial movement comes from
um the bank needed to raise Capital they
did a sale they had to do a second sale
to balance the losses that were on the
books from the first sale
both of those sales arguably were if not
required by at least kind of nudged by
regulations about what your books can
look like then they went into a quiet
period the SEC makes it illegal for you
to explain what you were doing while you
were doing stuff like this you literally
can't say to your depositors to your
investors hey guys
you know I could see how these two
transactions might make you nervous but
let me just explain real quick what
we're doing I think you'll see that it's
fine that's illegal which is why he did
this weird Don't Panic thing and then
was like is it because like he really
wasn't even probably supposed to say
that so there's at least one story here
where like it's the sec's fault and of
course I love that story because the SEC
is kind of always at fault
um
the uh Silicon Valley Bank is not the
bank that my husband's company uses but
it is the bank that many of the
companies he invests in uses and what he
said is like a lot of those companies
have failed
and as an equity investor failures are
expected but as a debt investor which is
what the bank is that many failures is
are bad that's like that's not how it
should work
um so there's clearly something going on
with the bank itself as well I don't
want to say you know but for the evil
SEC everything would be fine but I think
the very very idea that people will
raise that somehow deregulation is to
blame for this is bananas because these
banks are
hemmed in by more regulations than you
and I can possibly imagine on the
contrary I think deregulations are to
blame uh Nick Let's ignore that ever
happened and uh and maybe put a button
on this one I think I need to take an
email in all of the uh contractions that
have happened in the in the freakouts
and non-freakouts and the bailouts and
non-bailouts I can think of one in the
last like 25 years that didn't happen
the government did nothing uh and that
was the.com collapse of uh spring of
2001. it was kind of Glorious everyone
lost their job or a lot of people lost a
job I lost all those like Rich freelance
stuff for like industry standard
furniture.com type of magazines that
were paying a dollar a word it's awesome
uh and uh and it was Canadian dollars
too so it was like a buck 25 but it was
amazing um and nothing happened I how
disappointed argue that the obvious
animus that people have today uh towards
the especially the super out out there
extremely online Silicon Valley Tech
Bros who were like you have to bail this
out and it's not at all
um contradictory to everything that I
said last week about everything else
um we can't even convert that Mutual uh
animus tour the 90 of America does not
like those people and yet here we are I
I think that's uh really fascinating
political economy question because the
the tech sector didn't get bailed out
during the tech bubble although
sarbanes-oxley also you know while it
had to do with Enron and a couple of
other things it also kind of had to do
with the tech bubble bursting on some
level
uh but uh you know or this the idea that
the economy was made of twigs and was
you know it was all just kind of smoke
and mirrors
um I almost you know to be a little bit
conspiratorial maybe this is a gesture
on the part of the democratic party that
felt like it might be losing Silicon
Valley or whatnot uh this is a gift to
them to say hey you know what we're
going to take care of you and we'll
expect at some point in the near future
that you helped take care of us but it's
stunning because this you know Tech is
more hated now than it has ever been and
Silicon Valley you know has become a
vampire on the American economy and the
public imagination and for them
especially to be receiving
I hope that somebody smart and not
somebody like Donald Trump really makes
hay out of this because you know the the
one thing that was good about the
financial crisis is when people started
to say you know that businesses get to
keep their their gains but they
socialize their losses like big business
politically connected Industries Etc
that was absolutely true when we were
talking about the financial crisis and
we should start talking about that again
because that is a terrible way to run an
economy uh where you know the rich
people have enough clout so that they
never really lose it's just bad
it does feel like our heads are just
going to be crushed between the sides of
the political horseshoe forever now like
the idea that it's like there's there
must be a big chunk of the left that's
mad about this I remember Occupy Wall
Street I know those guys are still
around like Bernie Bernie is on the
board of a bank that just got guaranteed
too so it I mean he and right so there's
this gap between the rhetoric and the
reality there's this gap between the
principles and the execution and again
screw everybody who's out here being
like you know the real Hypocrites
Libertarians screw you guys uh let's uh
shift we've already previewed it a
little bit that uh lost somewhere in all
this hubbub uh was that President Biden
unveiled a 6.9 turillian
with a Tara dollar budget proposal
have you done a 10 trillion yet like a
terabyte or something a tetrabyte uh it
is true um so it's worth reminding
people that it is the Congress that is
constitutionally
um tasked with uh writing and uh passing
the budget uh and not the chief
executive but what we've seen the last
10 plus years is that as often as not
it's the president and the leaders in
Congress who sit down at the very last
minute and hash out their competing
Visions in a must pass chromabus on
December 17th
um so that's makes this worth looking at
a little bit more closely perhaps than
usual and also there's the constant
Democratic refrain
that budgets are actually statements of
our values so Peter um what values is
Joe Biden expressing with his proposed
budget
well I think one value he's uh he's he's
expressing is that he believes in uh in
fiscal nonsense
Malarkey that's right he's he's a big
Malarkey proponent it's important to him
and so he has enshrined malarkey
into into six trillion dollars worth of
it um no I think that the thing I want
to talk about here is his Medicare
solvency plan uh which is which is
notable for how much Malarkey is
involved and so what what Biden has done
is he has taken attacks that was part of
the Affordable Care Act uh the uh the
the
net investment income tax uh the H which
is sort of part of the hi payroll tax
right and this and so Obamacare uh
created a 3.8 percent tax that was on on
investment rich people et cetera right
the idea was oh this is just we're going
to tax the rich to pay for this
um and what by and that tax money just
went to uh to kind of the the general
fund um right like uh it wasn't
dedicated to pay for the Medicare trust
fund but what Biden has done is redirect
that money so that it specifically goes
into the Medicare trust fund the
hospital Insurance Fund that is set to
be insolvent by the end of this decade
now let's take this so what he's done is
is take a tax revenue stream that we
already had and just said well now we're
going to pretend that it goes directly
into the trust fund that's not raising
any new money
that's just redirecting money it doesn't
actually make the trust fund any more
solvent in any real sense it just sort
of says well now there's a dedicated
funding stream outside of the trust fund
itself and remember the trust fund was
supposed to be self-sustaining like what
it was created all those years ago right
so so it is an admission that the trust
fund which of course is an accounting
fiction to begin with that the trust run
is just like can't sustain itself and is
and it requires some sort of outside
funding so they've done that and then
they've also raised it because of course
when you create a new tax as they did
under Obamacare that creates
opportunities to to take that tax
and Ratchet it up and turn that dial
right so that you're getting more money
out of it you're taxing people even
harder and so this is this is in some
ways a preview of the democratic vision
for the entitlement state for Medicare
and particular but for just for old age
entitlements generally because right now
they're not sustainable and what it says
is basically we're going to have to do a
bunch of accounting tricks
that just create fake money and make
things look better on paper and then
also
also raise taxes a whole bunch
and that's the only way that we're going
to be able to make this sustainable at
all and even then we're still a couple
of decades at out from from yet again
running into insolvance Nick uh you're
sorry it's it's Malarkey and it's and
and it's uh it's partially it's a
fantasy but it's also revealing about
the Democratic vision for this sort of
thing because you know even if it's not
going to happen it's a it's a sense of
like this is this is what what it would
take uh let's let's presume a fictitious
non-mallarkical uh world for a second
what would be wrong with uh making the
old age entitlements formula uh more
solvent by lifting the cap on payroll
taxes and such and increasing taxes on
the rich
I I wanted to uh just put in a word for
plant-based malarkey I think we need
impossible Malarkey or Beyond Malarkey
um I would rather have that shove down
my throat than what we're getting now as
to the question that I asked you
yeah I mean part of it is that the these
systems are my my basic critique and I
believe in a social welfare state that
helps people who need it merely
continuing to tax unsustainable
entitlements that are Universal it just
it it increases the size scope and
spending of government you know we're
coming up on 70 percent of the federal
budget is going to be you know kind of
mandatory spending most of that between
Social Security and Medicare it's bad if
you are wealthy enough you should pay
for your own retirement and you should
pay for your own health care and merely
extending a system which ends up helping
uh relatively wealthy people uh you know
live a lifestyle that they have you know
is just wrong it takes money it robs
money from relatively young people and
gives and poor people and gives it to
relatively old and relatively wealthy
people
Catherine I hear though that uh at the
at least
um the Biden budgets uh reduce uh
deficits and the debt so that's good
right
God the lies Matt it's just more lies I
used to fight with you about whether it
was a good idea to accuse politicians of
lying when maybe they were just like
using different standards or operating
from different principles but this is
just a lie so
Biden's budget
um
would shrink the primary deficit which
is the shortfall of government revenue
to cover government expenses but that
ignores interest payments you know who
else ignored interest rates anyway
um the very interesting the future
the future projections about what
percent of the federal budget would be
consumed by
net interest
it's the it's the scariest graph you
will see and I guarantee you that they
will not be putting this on the White
House Instagram account with their
stupid lying stupid graphs
um by 2033 it's going to be 65 of the
budget interest rates just paying
interest the primary government spending
as a percentage of the federal deficit
is going to be 35 it's so little
compared with what we're dealing with in
terms of interest rates and Biden is
just pretending they're not there and so
therefore he got the deficit that's not
how money works all right we're going to
get to our listener email of the week
here in a moment but first a reminder
that this episode is sponsored by
betterhelp friends
do you really know yourself are you the
same person that you were five years ago
10 years ago or maybe nine days ago when
you didn't have covid you weren't
preparing your taxes and your house
wasn't infested with lice if your being
has indeed changed with the
circumstances have you also adjusted
your self-conception and your way of
operating in the world therapy with a
trained independent Arbiter can be a
worthwhile way of deepening your
self-awareness re-jiggering your
interior operating system and coping
better with what the world throws at
your face that's where better help
online therapy comes in
better help is easy to use super
flexible entirely online just fill out a
quick questionnaire and start increasing
your self-knowledge right away you can
discover your potential with better help
just visit betterhelp.com Roundtable
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
dot com slash Roundtable go there today
you'll be glad you did all right
reminder to email us your readably short
queries to Roundtable at reason.com this
one comes from Chris from down the
street from our DC office that doesn't
sound creepy at all Chris writes in part
I read your website every day thank you
Chris and the reason Roundtable is a
regular fixture in my life thank you
Chris I also enjoy the recent interview
thank you Chris and hope to one day go
to New York to watch the Soho Forum in
person
more TK I run small businesses and we
are regularly affected by anti-free
market Decisions by our City local
government most of the people I know
celebrate these for Equity or fairness
or whatever reasons despite these
regulations actively hurting our
businesses and most of all our employees
my question is what book would you
recommend for my status establishment
friendly friends colleagues to maybe get
them thinking about free market
principles Catherine
I recommend very very short books people
aren't going to read long books maybe
even just stories I know there has been
a lot of discussion about whether in
fact the how many layers of irony are on
this short story but I still recommend
Kurt vonnegut's Harrison Bergeron which
is a very good simple understandable
lesson about maybe why Equity isn't all
it's cracked up to be
um also maybe some bastiat but honestly
I would start with Harrison Bergeron
Nick Gillespie
I'm going to go with a uh
you know a sacred text map that uh Dr
zayas finds at the end of Planet of the
Apes called the Declaration of
Independence how libertarian politics
what's wrong with America
you would think this man who lives down
the street from us should give people a
copy of the Declaration because I know
when they're like hey I think the
signage regulations you know the uh and
the reason for that is because I've had
a bunch of people and by that I mean I
think three people who are not
libertarian stumble across it in recent
in the recent past meaning about the
past month and they all said you know
what this was really fun delightful and
it made me rethink a lot of things so
what part of the iuhasca experience was
that that was all of it man and you know
it's really it's more of an ibogaine uh
trip you know it's it's much more
intense Ayahuasca only lasts for you
know a thousand years this is like 10
000 years
Peter Peter uh besides the second dick
that recommendation what would you
recommend
yeah I mean Catherine is obviously
correct here that it should be Harrison
uh Bergeron but let me take this in a
slightly different direction on the one
hand I recognize that this is a bad idea
and on the other hand I kind of think
that he should try giving his friends
Atlas what is wrong with you and I get I
get he's yeah that's that it's long yeah
and I get that Ein Rand has a reputation
yeah and that people like have a natural
reaction when they see the words Atlas
Shrugged and Ein Rand in that cover with
the you know the the guy holding up the
world and the whole thing and so maybe
the way to do this
rip off the cover and the cover page but
also like
also maybe the back half of the book
like just like the first 150 Pages or so
rand's wishes but what that book does
what the like we could have a whole like
a whole hour just on that book but what
that book does at its best is it just
reinforces over and over and over again
that authorities public authorities in
particular who are operating in many
though not all cases with genuinely good
intentions set up rules and regulations
that end up having unintended negative
consequences in particular on businesses
and that those that they that they that
those uh those rules end up backfiring
they end up hurting the people that they
are designed to help and so in some ways
Harrison Bergeron Kurt Vonnegut makes
that point in a in a funnier and sort of
uh you know in much uh quicker manner
but but Atlas Shrugged is actually
really good at just reinforcing that
point and just saying look these people
are going to make these rules and of
course some of them are actually kind of
bad people but a lot of the people who
are agitating for the rules they're good
they would like to see them put in place
for good reasons because they're decent
people and they feel like this is this
is how to be a good person and yet when
you put those rules in place inevitably
there will be unintended but often
predictable consequences that will
backfire and hurt the people that
they're all right I'm gonna actually
attempt an answer to the question damn
it uh and that is to for those of your
people that actually read books pursuant
to Catherine's uh
uh not just volinski story not just yet
although that is a classic that'll scare
you straight from so many different
things uh is uh the future and its
enemies uh by Virginia her great late
90s book um that talks about uh dynamism
and and statism
uh and it gives a especially for people
who are going to be allergic to the word
libertarian which is not overemphasized
in the book
um gives basic this is how things work
and uh teaches you about economics along
the way which is uh the point of your
query
um I if these people don't read which is
likely
um they can also uh see the history or
beautiful uh Tales of unattended
consequences at recent TV by uh the
Glorious Austin uh Bragg at all uh and
uh that will also teach you what Peter
just talked about and if you really
can't read and are on Twitter all the
time uh follow the human progress
account from KO Institute which just
tells you like hey look this good thing
happened and it keeps happening where
there's capitalism
um and then people might click on the
link and follow it from there
um and good luck and Godspeed and and
you know don't don't creep out
um uh Peter and Catherine in the booth
from
no come say hi we like it when people
come to the office on Friday at like 4
45 so that we can stop working and have
a beer things have changed around there
uh
so but now you admit that people lie
okay lightning round uh on Thursday the
Republican run house Judiciary select
subcommittee on the weaponization of the
federal government that's really what
it's called
uh invited journalists Matt taibi and
Michael Schellenberg to testify about
their work on the ongoing Twitter files
investigations uh so-called after new
owner Elon Musk opened up some of his
archives for various journalists to
peruse the company's cozy relationship
with censorious types in and around
governments particularly as concerns
content related to kovid January 6th
riots Hunter Biden's laptop and alleged
Russian disinformation
taibi uh who has long been understood as
considerably left of center and
schellenberger who's kind of a Centrist
Democrat type I don't know how he calls
himself these days but that's how it
used to be uh were subject to just
amazing contempt
by Democratic lawmakers on the it is
fantastic click the links on all those
people uh they were described variously
as so-called journalists uh as in one
case actively dangerous they're good
they're dangerous
that's right I'm dangerous uh and as
profiteering in an unseemly way from
their Twitter files work uh taibi wrote
a piece about it that I recommend called
the Democrats have lost the plot
Catherine uh quickly can you ruminate
how the Democrats have indeed lost the
plot yeah I
looking at Matt taibi's face during that
whole
episode like I've never identified more
with a person on C-Span than in that
moment like so many of the questions you
could just see him and he wrote about
this in his newsletter like he describes
his experience there largely of being
one of him not being sure if they had
really asked the question that was as
stupid as the question they seem to have
asked was
and then having it slowly down on him
that yes the stupid question was the one
they had asked and then trying to figure
out how to not say
you know to an elected representative of
the people in the United States wow that
question is so stupid as to be
unanswerable over and over and over and
that
for the most part was what was going on
as far as I could tell
um this hearing shouldn't have existed
in the first place and
um
I think the conduct during that hearing
made that point better than I think that
that hearing is perfectly legitimate my
God I'm talking about the government
leaning on a social media company to
censor individual voices I want to hear
about that Catherine I think it just
wasn't it was never gonna it wasn't this
was not gonna be it's a congressional
hearing that's I know I think I think
what it illuminated yeah exactly yeah we
agree that I think it what it
illuminated is how
unfucking believably dumb Congress is I
mean really it you know it should be
mandatory viewing you know if if school
kids had to watch the space shuttle blow
up they should be watching this
it is just so you know I I watch that as
a school kid in real time yeah maybe it
didn't work because you still like NASA
right yeah now right but it's like no
rocket what I loved about this too is it
took that you know during the uh like
the Facebook hearings and the earlier uh
in 2018 the social media things where
you know Pat Leahy and Dianne Feinstein
were shaking their Jitterbug phones at
Mark Zuckerberg or whatever and like can
you help me you know make stop making
get you know make these weird noises or
something like that this the people who
are asking the questions were
significantly younger and possibly
significantly Dumber it was it was
fantastic and uh I say this to somebody
I worry about the the decline in
confidence and Trust in government and
this one man this this is the equivalent
of the svb bankrupt like nobody should
be believing in Government after
watching even five minutes of that and
my favorite bit which is why really
circulated was when uh a congresswoman
suggested that Matt taibi Michael
schellenberger at Barry Weiss were in a
threesome yeah you know uh or like are
you part of a threesome and like and
it's just clear like there are just like
squirrels in the heads of Congress
people running around they're like they
make Homer Simpson look like Albert
Einstein
um Peter what was your reaction watching
this I mean I'm with Nick the best
reason to oppose government oversight of
social media and other media is
listening to members of Congress talk
about social media
and other media
um all right let's go to our end of uh
podcast what we have been consuming in
the cultural sphere Nick let's go to you
first
all right thank you and I am uh I
watched uh partly because it was
nominated for an Oscar uh for short
documentary it did not win but the
Martha Mitchell effect which is
available on Netflix came out last year
um and it was it's by uh Ann alberg uh
the director and alberg and it is a
fantastic look at one of the most
interesting but kind of Forgotten in
time now uh aspects of the Watergate
um uh conspiracy and whatnot where
Martha Mitchell was married to John
Mitchell the absolutely scumbag uh
Attorney General of Richard Nixon and
she noticed uh when she was watching a
TV account of the break into the
Watergate that she knew one of the
burglars and that uh she wouldn't shut
up about it she and she thought she was
protecting her husband from a cover-up
that was going to you know you know kind
of take him down not realizing that he
was you know neck deep in in doing the
cover-up and things like that and she
was gaslit by the Nixon White House who
started saying she was a drunk she was
held you know a captive by the
government Etc and it gave rise to a
psychological um kind of uh term the
Martha Mitchell effect that was coined
in the late 80s by a psychologist who
said this is what happens when people
talk publicly of things that seem to
make them mark them as delusional but
they end up being right
um I highly recommend watching the
Martha Mitchell effect it's a brilliant
uh kind of window on to a chat a very
[__] up and dark chapter in American
history and the way the presidency and
the government use the media to certain
types of effect and ultimately failed uh
Martha Mitchell I should also add if
you're if you're my age and Matt I
suspect maybe you remember her too she
was this ghostly figure in you know in
my early childhood of like of an insane
woman like a housewife who yapped too
much that was her big problem she was
Lippy and mouthy and insane and it
turned out she was absolutely right it's
it's kind of it's a fantastic
anti-government piece as well as a
feminist piece in the best way possible
the Martha Mitchell effect
very very sassy and also uh Catherine uh
what did you consume uh first I need to
issue a correction from a previous what
I'm consuming uh helpful alert listener
Wade who has been a home Brewer and a
reason subscriber for three decades
writes in to say that while I am correct
that the Belgian beer that I recommended
does use sugar which makes it somewhat
distinctive the thing that really
matters is the unique phenolic character
of the Belgian yeast my apologies to
those who were hanging on my beer
analysis it is not the show what is that
it's still what's that term you used
what was the adjective of the yeast
it's I don't know I don't know enough
but Wade knows thank you Wade for
straightening me out
um my recommendation is the podcast dear
Hank and John
it is uh the green brothers and I
continue to recommend their work despite
being told that they are cringe I don't
care
um I have recommended on this podcast in
the past uh John Green's anthropocene
reviewed both the Pod and the book in
which he rates human stuff on a
five-star scale
um it's out on paperback I think this
week
um but dear Hank and John is these two
brothers
these two brothers who are like just
YouTubers from way back
um and they do reader questions and then
they give the news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon which seems to be a soccer
team
um and they kind of live in the space
between like science and existentialism
which is a space that I enjoy
so it's stuff like
um can fish see water and what is the
difference between an ology and anonymy
and how do I be brave in the dark and
stuff like that
um I will also recommend this podcast
despite the fact that there are regular
sides in it about how billionaires are
the dumbest worstest and that they are a
sign that things are wrong with our
society these guys are not Libertarians
and you know what they still make good
stuff so it's fine you can enjoy things
that don't have your politics dear Hank
and John a podcast if you like as I
suspect you do since you made it to the
end of this one podcasts were a couple
the few people chat about weird stuff
Peter what kind of weird stuff did you
consume last night
so I watched the 95th Academy Awards so
I have um complicated feelings about the
Oscars because I love movies but I don't
care that much about the awards and the
celebrities and all the rest of that I
often find the ceremony kind of annoying
and exasperating or just plain boring
sometimes and even when I think the
academy is awarding good movies as they
did last night with everything
everywhere all at once which is a great
movie and came away the big winner it
also often just sort of comes across as
self-serving and not quite random but
pretty close given the selections over
the years but because I love movies and
because I think movies are important I
will also admit that sometimes these
ceremonies can get to me and there there
are moments that really that that stand
out and that you know I almost want to
say they matter and in particular last
night the best supporting actor award
went to the former child actor and
immigrant um ke Hoy Quan uh so you may
remember him as Short Round from Indiana
Jones and the Temple of Doom he was also
in The Goonies uh worked a little bit
after that and then basically took 20
something years off from acting worked a
little bit behind the scenes did some
fight coordination that sort of thing
and then came back and was in everything
everywhere all at once for which he won
an Oscar and so this is a guy who fled
the Communists in Vietnam he right like
he just sort of tried to get out right
and came to America and he is so proud
to be an American right and just like
crying up there and saying look this is
the American dream
honestly a great moment a great movie a
great moment a great performance totally
deserved it was the I believe it was the
very first award they handed out and it
was the high he was robbed uh he should
have got one for being short round uh
let's just uh be honest about that
fantastic sure someone on Twitter uh
last night was like uh uh what we really
need is him acting in a follow-up to
Indiana Jones the Temple of Doom where
he tries to
um return all the treasures that Indiana
Jones stole back to their rightful
owners which you could call back to the
Holy Land exhibition recommendation that
I made uh last time and speaking uh
we're doing callbacks to Matt's previous
recommendations now indeed uh and
speaking of my fondness for small
Southern California based museums that I
visited in February
um Catherine's comments about Colombia
blowing up reminded me of all kinds of
of fun memories
um and one of them is that I visited did
a place I didn't know that it existed
until I was like hey where can I take my
dad uh away from the old folks home that
isn't that far uh and it is the Columbia
Memorial Space Center in Downey
California it is a great tiny little
Museum just like two floors pretty small
uh containable set up for kids uh so you
can do a thing or figure out like how to
uh like you hitch up a a a a a space pod
an Apollo thing onto different types of
uh parachutes see which one you can
steer to land on the floor in the right
place goes up a floor that's really cool
you can make a paper airplane and try to
make it the most aerodynamic and put it
in little thing and go and then and see
how far you get through the thing uh
that's great
uh and there's uh
I'm sorry so are there a lot of
activities where you crash
discomfortable craft it's pretty fun
it's NASA wow listen Catherine we've
we've put to a high price on on lives
now it's uh there's also memorials about
the astronauts who perish that are it's
very well done and and uh Apollo stuff
but it's just a great little museum for
kids
um it's on the site where there used to
be North American
um which was then uh replaced by or
changed its name to Rockwell
International where my father worked for
15 years didn't work at that site for
the most part worked in Seal Beach not
that no one cares but um it's great uh
and I just a shout out to the people who
run it when they saw that there was an
old aerospace engineer coming through
um they made a beeline and like you know
thanked him for his service and uh and
they have a regular Meetup of the
old-timers who sit around and tell just
terrible lies about their security
clearances uh and whatever uh it's a
really sweet tiny uh little Museum in
Downey California
um and uh and it'll teach you about
shuttle and it's again good for kids
check it out Columbia Memorial Space
Center and there's a big shopping mall
across the street
um and a lot of restaurant options just
want to make sure that people are aware
of that
um that's all the awareness specials
they're chilies it was taken Nick you do
you you damn right
um that is all the time that we and in
and out a Waffle House I think in and
out not a waffle house we don't really
do that in California
um not enough hurricanes to make that
yes uh is is your dad at a stage now
where he's willing to spring for the
sour cream on the baked potato mat
he's like you know don't hold back
uh yeah he's he's lost he's lost F's to
give that is uh that is that is for damn
sure
um uh so that's all the time we have uh
thank you for listening
um if you like what we do go to
reason.com podcasts uh Nick do you have
anything to announce about future New
York events uh yeah on Monday April 3rd
there will be a reason Speakeasy at the
blue building on 46th Street between
second and third Avenue uh where I'll be
interviewing the authors of the
individualists a uh intellectual history
of the modern libertarian movement and
what the future looks like that's uh
John tomasi of heterodox Academy and
Matt wolinski a uh philosopher at the
University of San Diego it's a fantastic
book it's a fantastic venue and we
always have fantastic crowds that's
Monday April 3rd go to reason.com
events and you can uh you'll find a link
to tickets and all that kind of stuff
speaking of events just get yourself
preliminarily excited we're going to do
a live Round Table in an evening setting
in or around New York City
possibly at the end of next month more
details TK as they say In The
journalistic Biz but it's going to be
very exciting and we hope to see you in
person and uh you know
um uh maybe Peter will teach us how to
make cocktails or something during the
event um so stay tuned for all of that
if you like what we do as an
organization and I hope you do if you
listen this far please go to reason.com
donate and see how you can support us in
our endeavors
get it um all right thank you uh goodbye
and have a pleasant spot
[Music]